well the the large issues I think our
how are we as a as a people as
individuals States country going to deal
with the challenges of globalization
over the pair of the future are we going
to be driven out by these forces or are
we going to be willing to grasp them and
to shape them and to turn them into our
advantage I think that's a central
challenge and that means investing in
people investing in education skills
other kinds of issues or questions and I
think a follow-up answer to that is to
understand the strengths of the nation
which is our values that's what we are
when we are respected as a country
that's what we're respected for though
those are the values which are inscribed
both in the Declaration of Independence
and also in in the in the Constitution
those are the values that were expressed
yeah in the in the in the ship mate the
Mayflower with a Mayflower Compact about
our sense of community and the value of
being together it's described in the
Constitution the general welfare of our
nation that's when we have been an hour
best and I think those are that's our
greatest strength the greatest challenge
i think is whether we're going to be how
we're going to cope with the central
challenges of a rapidly changing world
and i think the other great challenges
how we're going to maintain this
strength of sense of community and value
which has been such a compelling force
in the shaping our own lives and also in
shaping the lives